there is none
greater than the
[Music]
Creator there is none
greater than the
[Music]
Creator
la
[Music]
for
m
[Music]
can
for
[Music]
in
for
[Music]
in
for
[Music]
r
the
[Music]
if
for
[Music]
alhamdulillah
my special elders and my dear brothers
and sisters I welcome all of you with
the Islamic
greetings may peace mercy and blessings
of Allah subhana tala be on all of
you it's a pleasure for me to be once
again back to London especially Harrow
after a span of8
months the topic of this evening's talk
is seeking knowledge in the light of
Islam your children are an AM give them
the best education for both the worlds
it is a long topic but it basically
dealing with seeking knowledge in light
of
Islam and that your children are an am
so give them the best education for both
the
worlds Allah subhana wa ta'ala
in the Glorious Quran the first guidance
that he gave to the whole of humankind
it was not to pray it was not to fast it
was not to perform Haj but the first
guidance given by Allah subhana wa
ta'ala in the Glorious Quran to the
whole of humankind
was it was to read it was to recite it
was to Proclaim and I started my talk by
quoting few verses from the Quran from
Surah chapter Number
96 verse number 1 to5 where Allah
says which means read recite and
Proclaim in the name of thy Lord Lord
who has created who has created the
human beings from something which clings
a Le like substance read the Lord is
most
Bountiful he who has taught the use of
pen has taught men that which he knew
not though Allah subhana wa ta'ala has
given us the first guidance in the
Glorious Quran that we should read but
unfortunately we
realize that the Muslims in the Muslim
Community
everyone does not read and those Muslims
who are involved in knowledge in Reading
they don't read as per the guidance of
Allah subhana tala Allah does not say
only read Allah
says read in the name of thy Lord so
when we read when we acquire knowledge
we should acquire knowledge in such a
way that we come closer to our creator
Allah subhana wa tala if the
knowledge does not bring you closer
towards your creator towards your R then
that knowledge is not useful for
the and our beloved Prophet Muhammad
sallah Al wasallam said it's
aith which is mentioned in MA Hadith
number 224 our beloved Prophet
said seeking
knowledge is obligatory on every Muslim
seeking knowledge is obligatory on every
Muslim man or woman it's
compulsory that every Muslim should
acquire
knowledge and it is the duty of us
Muslims to see to it that we
knowledge many of us we think that
knowledge is only what we study in
school schools in colleges and
universities education and
knowledge starts at
home and the best teacher is the
mother it is the duty of the parents to
see to it that they properly educate the
children see to it that they give them
proper
education because the child when he or
she is born they are not responsible for
the environment they born it is the duty
of the parents to see to it that
irrespective of the environment they
give them proper
education and today we find that there
are various
societies and the various ways of life
in these
societies we have the Islamic way of
life we have the Western way of life and
we have a variety of different ways of
life as far as Islam is
concerned Islam is a complete way of
life it caters both to the spiritual
aspect of the Soul as well as the
physical aspect of the
body and Allah says in the Quran in
Surah MAA chapter number 5 verse number
three on this day have I completed your
religion for
you and have completed my favor for you
and I've chosen for you Islam so once
Islam is completed nothing new can be
added or subtracted from it our de is
complete so as far as the way of life is
concerned Islam is a complete way of
life when we mix Islam with the other
societies and other ways of life and
other
cultures whichever culture we're living
in if that part of the culture is not
against the Islamic Sharia is not
against the Quran and the
S we do not
mind following or agreeing with that
culture but if that culture if that
Society goes against Quran and say
Hadith we should not follow it Islam is
number
one and now we find that many of times
while upbringing our children we have a
problem because of the differen in
societies and
cultures and we're aware of the western
society as many of the Muslims they
living in West society and we find
that though the Western Society it is
advanced in science and
technology but as far as moral values
are concerned they are
declining we find in the western society
that alcoholism is on the increase drug
addic on the increase OBS is on the
increase adulter is on the increase rape
is on the increase crime is on the
increase while educating our children we
should see to it that we give them a
proper Islamic education and while we
train them and upbring them in a western
Society or any society in the world it
may be an Eastern Society also we should
see to it that we should make them a
good Muslim that is one who submits his
will to Allah subhana wa taala Islam
comes from the root word
Salam which means
peace it's also derived from the Arabic
word s
which means to submit your will to Allah
subhana wa tala so Islam means peace
acquired by submitting a will to Allah
subhana wa tala and any person who
acquires Peace by submitting his will to
Allah subhana wa ta'ala he is called as
a
Muslim while educating our children we
should see to it that we should not get
so much impressed by the Western Society
we should only take the correct values
from the society we don't want our
children to become alcoholics
to become drug
addicts to become adulterers to become
rapists we want them to be good Muslims
who submit the will to Allah subhana wa
ta'ala
and our beloved Prophet Muhammad sallah
Ali wasallam said that every child he is
born
in means the innate
religion every child is born as a Muslim
he submits the will to Allah subhana wa
tala
later on the elders the parents the
teachers they influence the child he may
remain on the straight path or he may
become a fire worshipper he may become
an idol worshipper and then he may go
outside the fold of Islam but every
child initially irrespective whether
he's born in a Hindu family whether he's
born in a Christian family a Jewish
family or a Muslim family he is born as
a Muslim he submits civil to Allah subh
later on by the influence of other
people parents teachers Elders he may go
on the wrong track that's the reason
whenever any non-muslim he accepts
Islam the more appropriate and correct
word is
rever he was on the straight path he
went on the wrong track and then he came
back on the straight path on the
straight track so the correct word is
r
and we have got proof and
evidence that every child he is born
in there were researches done on two
tribes the kapaku tribe and the
Australian aborigin tribe these two
tribes did not come in contact with
modern civilization till as late as
1950 and later on when researchers went
and tried to find out what was the way
of life it was everything of Islam but a
name they not call themselves Muslims
but they believed in one God they
believe that God did not have any Idols
or
images they believed he was not
begotten when they worshiped the god
they did the suud they
prostrated they were following the
basics of Islam but they didn't call
them themselves Muslims so if we let a
child after he's born if we do not
influence him with any of the teachings
that child will grow up to be a Muslim
that is the inate religion it is the
duty of the parents that once the child
is born they should see to it that they
give that child a proper environment to
live and to continue
life it is the duty of the parents that
they should see to it that they give
proper education to the
children and many of us we are worried
about the education of a
children i' would like to ask a question
that
when is the
time you should start thinking about
educating your child what is Right Time
can anyone give the answer that which is
the right time when do you start
thinking what you want to make your
child or what you want to make him what
should you be in life which is the right
time which is the right
time right from the
beginning
as soon as he
understands sorry when he starts to
think to get a child he may start
thinking after 10
years which is the right time 7 years
old 7 years old 2 years old when he can
understand when he's born one year old
one year old fine here we have different
options yeah somebody saying 3 years old
3 years old somebody saying 3 years old
somebody saying 2 years old somebody
saying one year old some think when he's
born
islamically the time to think of
educating a
child the latest you should think latest
huh maximum is when you choose your life
partner when you choose your life
partner is the
time you have to think about educating
your child because the parents are the
best teacher especially the mother
that's the time if you want to make your
child Islamic you should see to it that
you have a spouse who Islamic if you
don't have Islamic spouse how would you
expect your child to be Islamic so
depending upon how you want to upbring
your child is the time you start
thinking when you choose your life
partner that does not mean already those
who are married should choose a new life
partner some people ask me now I'm
already mad what should I
do it is better late than
never you can start start molding your
life partner into that style no problem
you can do dawa with the life partner so
you should realize that the best time to
start thinking about educating your
child the latest is when you choose a
life partner as I was saying our beloved
Prophet mhammad sahi wasallam said it's
a say Hadith which mentioned in MA
Hadith number 224 I beloved Prophet
said seeking
knowledge
Muslim is obligatory on every Muslim
seeking knowledge is obligatory on every
Muslim man or woman now when we give
knowledge to our
children we have to see to it that we
give them proper knowledge knowledge can
be broadly divided into two
types one is the basic knowledge of
Islam and second knowledge what is
required by the community it's the duty
of every parent
that he should
educate the children with the proper
Islamic knowledge number one most
important ised that believing in one
Allah subhana wa tala and we should not
associate partners with anyone to Allah
subhana wa taala Allah subhana wa tala
should not be associated with anyone
elseed number one then all the pillars
which most of us know but we should
impart it in the right way to our
children about Salah
about zakat about Hajj about fasting is
very
important and but natural knowledge of
the
Quran this Quran is the last and final
revelation of Allah subhana wa taala
which was revealed to the last and final
messenger Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him yesterday in
Bradford I had a talk on alquran should
it be read with understanding and I told
there that the best gift that a PA
parent can give to the child is the
Quran and make the child understand the
Quran most of us Muslims we teach our
children to read Arabic they can read
Arabic but they can't understand if we
teach them the language of the Quran the
Arabic as a language that is the best
gift you can give and inshallah towards
the end of my talk I will deal and
discuss with that in detail the second
type of knowledge is the knowledge
required by the community knowledge
which makes a person a doctor
makes a person an engineer a lawyer a
scientist an agriculturist this is too
required for the betterment of the
community for the betterment of the
society but when we are acquiring the
second type of knowledge we should see
to it that when we acquire scientific
knowledge when we learn about
mathematics geography history this
knowledge should get you closer to Allah
subhana wa ta'ala should not take you
away from Allah subhana wa taala if if
this knowledge takes you away from Allah
subhana wa ta'ala that knowledge is not
correct knowledge it's not correct
education it should bring you closer to
Allah subhana wa tala for example when
we learn medicine we learn how to save
the lives of thousands of human beings
but in that same medical
knowledge when we learn how to do
abortion there are youngsters who are
doing Zena and then they want to abort
so using this knowledge for activities
which are wrong we should abstain from
that abortion for saving the life of the
mother if she has a health problem Islam
gives permission otherwise Allah says in
Sur is chapter number 17 verse number 31
and Sur Anam chapter number 6 verse
number 151 that kill not your children
for want of sustainance killing of
children is prohibited so whatever
knowledge you acquire it should be for
the betterment of humanity and get you
closer to Allah tala whatever moral
values you are learning we should see to
it that when we put our children in the
school that school should upbring the
children properly imagine if we put our
children in the condent
school many of whose values don't match
with the value of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala it is like we are tying the hands
and legs of our children and putting
them in water and asking them to sleep
swim how will they swim so when we put
them in a school see to it you put them
in a proper
school if the culture and society and
the school teaches you manners it should
be good Islamic manners nowadays we find
that in the western culture they say
that manners is building old age
homes Islam has got no place for old age
homes because Islam believes that we
should love and respect our parents and
there are several verses in the
Quran lman 31 vers number 15ab chapter
number 29 verse number 8 suram chapter
number 6 verse number 151 several verses
which say that we have enjoined on the
human beings that to be kind and good to
your
parents and our beloved Prophet M
wasallam said it's mentioned inkari verm
number eight in the book of AD chapter
number two Hadith number two the the
person who approached the prophet and he
asked him that who deserves the maximum
love and companionship in the world so
the prophet
said your mother the man asked after
that who the prophet again repeated your
mother the man asked after that who
again the prophet said for the third
time your mother the man asked after
that who then the prophet said your
father 75% 34 of the love and
companionship goes to the the mother 25%
1/4 goes to the father in short mother
gets the gold medal she get the silver
medal as well as the bronze medal the
father has to be satisfied with the m
consolation
price so Islam teaches that we have to
love our parents and especially as far
as companionship is concerned the mother
gets three times
more so in Islam there is no place for
old age homes so whatever manners and
eates that we teach our children it
should be in line with what our cre
Allah subhana tala
wants and we find today that Muslims are
in the firing
line we find that Muslims have become
backward as far as science technology is
concerned as far as education is
concerned and the main reason is because
we have gone away from the Quran and
Sunnah previously from the eth to the
12th century it was called as the Dark
Ages dark for whom dark for the
Europeans the amount of advances the
Muslim Arabs made it is
phenomenal and if we read history what
we read in school I myself I've passed
from a convent
school a Christian Missionary School
I've got my education from
there it's later on afterwards I realize
that what I read in school and in my
Medical College i a doctor many things
is something different we are taught in
school that the blood
circulation was first discovered with
Willam hav in fact you read the Quran
Quran speaks about the blood circulation
inah chapter number 16 verse number 66
how does the food enter into the stomach
then from there it go in the intestine
from the intestine why the bloodstream
to various organs of the body including
the mamory glands which responsible for
the production of milk it speaks about
the production of milk and about the
blood circulation in a nutshell inel 16:
66 after I did research I came to know
that the first human being who first
described the blood circulation
wasf 600 years after the Quran was
revealed and 400 years before William
hav but when we read in our
textbook we are told about Willam how
many of us know about how many of us
hardly anyone knows that Naf was the
first person who described the blood
circulation we learn about geography but
the person who drew the first world map
of geography was Ali in
1154 what we study the digits in school
you know what this called it is called
as Arabic numerals the 1 2 3 4 that we
use for writing 1 2 34 it is called as
Arabic
numerals the other is a Roman
numeral the Indians were the people who
first discovered about the zero and the
Arabs took it from there and made it
famous to the world B adding a decimal
that's how we have the system today we
learn in mathematics about the
Pythagoras Theorem that the square of
the
hypotenuse in a triangle is equal to the
sum of the square of the other two sides
the Pythagoras Theorem that we learned
in school it was first discovered by Al
so we know that Muslims few centuries
back they were advanced in science and
technology but when we read in our
textbook today they hardly
mentioned who is the father of
trigonometry it is
aluni have you heard of alindi alindi
wrote 200 Works in mathematics in
geometry in logic and at a time when
Galileo Des artist and Newton when they
said that all physical laws absolute he
said that it was relative later on
Albert Einstein did more research and he
propounded the theory of
relativity when we read history we come
to know that Muhammad Ahmed and Hassan
Shakir these brothers they measured the
surface area of the Earth by measuring
angle at the Red Sea at a time when
people thought the world was
flat we learn chemist
history and we are told that gabber is
the person who discovered alcohol it is
jaban jabir when they write in our
textbook gber gber sounds like a
Westerner gber it is
jaban when we read we think it's a
western gber gber and
Ja he discovered alcohol and the word
alcohol comes from the Arabic word alul
meaning evil
spirit when we history we come to know
about Muhammad zakar
arazi he was advanced in the field of
medicine and even wrote books on Mees
and small
box when we read
medicine we know that Al
Abbas he wrote 20 volumes on practice
and theory of
medicine we are told about Aina AA the
Aral of the East it is
aliina aliina he was called as the
Aristotle of the East you are the
philosopher you are the
mathematician so when we go back to
history and we see that we Muslims we
were on top of the world the reason we
were on top of the world at that time is
because at that time we were close to
the Quran and Sunnah now we have gone
away from Quran and Sunnah and that's
the reason we are in the firing line we
should see to it that we upbring our
children close to the Quran and
the it is a duty that we give give our
children proper
education that's the reason I say that
your children are your am see to it you
give them proper
education for both the
worlds
and this was a dilemma that I faced
maybe eight years
back and though
alhamdulillah I used to give talks on
education and I did take time to choose
my life partner because I want the right
life partner and finally Allah gave me
alhamdulillah
and when the children are born my eldest
son is 12 years old and I always had
that thing that we should have a proper
school which has a striking balance
between the Islamic education and the
formal education I don't call
mathematics science as secular education
because secular by definition means
nothing to do with God I believe science
believes in God mathematics is Islamic
subject so therefore when I talk about
the other conventional subjects I call
them formal education mathematics
science history geography English we
call it as formal subjects so I always
had that dream that to have a school
which has the Striking
balance
between the Islamic
subjects Islamic education and the
formal education
because mathematics science history
according to me are part of
Islam and that made me to the world and
I did a survey alhamdulillah of most of
the Islamic schools at that time that
was about 6 to 8 years back in a span of
2 three years mashallah I went to most
of the best schools of the world in
America in Canada in UK in South Africa
in Australia in Malaysia and I visited
hundreds of
schools and when I observed that in the
Western
countries most of the Islamic schools
almost all they were more of a Muslim
managed
School Muslim managed School means the
management was Muslim but I would not
call them as Islamic schools because we
realize that in the Western
World there is a fear of alcoholism
of drug addiction about Obin so in these
schools we found that the dress code
that the students wore there were
Islamic hijab mashallah they had a time
for prayer for Salah alhamdulillah there
was no alcohol there was no drug
alhamdulillah so that was what was
called the Islamic school where back in
India most of the Muslim man schools
they have the Islamic dress code you can
offer Salah there's no alcohol there's
no drug so I did not find something new
but alhamdulillah considering the
Western
Country where drug addiction is common
alcoholism is common obsin is common it
is an achievement which I was happy but
what I came to search for that when our
children go to school they should get
the best of knowledge I could not find
any of the
schools what we wanted that we have now
the Muslim umah rather divide into two
types of Education one type of education
when we have
education they
acquire the So-Cal secular education
which are called as formal education
they acquire knowledge of mathematics
science history geography but they are
far away from the dean on the other hand
when we go to our madrasas we teach
about Quran Hadith Shar alhamdulillah
may Allah give them reward but they are
unaware of mathematics science history
geography so we wanted a balance between
the two
to have the best of both which when
visited most of the schools that I
visited now the thing is changing in the
past six years I realized that some
schools have become slightly closed
alhamdulillah to the concept that I have
but most of the schools they may be
having maybe three periods a
week on Islam or maybe one period a day
maximum I came across was two periods a
day on Islam and
and what was the main objective that a
child when he passes from school he
should have the knowledge of Quran Hadi
Shar and science Etc that I could not
find though I visited the best of
schools in America in South Africa which
is supposed to be very much advanced in
this field of Islamic schools UK
Australia Malaysia Etc so that we
thought that let's make an effort and
with Allah
alhamdulillah we in Bombay alhamdulillah
about approximately 6 years back or or
rather 5 and a half years back we
launched our own Islamic school by the
name of Islamic international school
because for my children we had to do
it though I was prepared to SE with that
gear up my child though putting in a
convent school by giving all the so-call
education at home but then we thought
that we should make a sample school and
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah we venture
with this project in Bombay and Allah
helped us and with Allah support we
launched the school and alhamdulillah
from day one the response that we
received from the people of Bombay from
the Muslims of Bombay was tremendous
masallah the response was such that
though the school was absolutely new we
hardly publicized it we decided to start
the school there was only 3 weeks
publicity mashallah but immediately when
the school was launched the amount of
response we got was phenomenal and it
was overwhelming that
ministers they phoned our school to see
to it that some of the friends get
admission to the school it was good
mashallah you'll hardly find a minister
phoning a madrasa and telling that you
know I want to sit in your madrasa we
find that in the convent school in India
mostly the convent school The Minister's
phone and they try and use the influence
but alhamdulillah we are very strict as
far as admission criteria is concerned
we are very strict with the guidelines
and unless a person fulfills our
guidelines let him be minister so we
don't give admission
alhamdulillah the difference that is
there that we appreciated that the
movement that was
started by many of the philanthropists
and educationist throughout the world it
was a good movement at least giving them
an environment of Islam so I was really
happy that in the Western countries
whether it been USA UK there were
schools in which a child could at least
practice his Islam when the school that
we
launched we a different system we
had that I wanted a striking balance
that when a child passes the 10th
standard he should become at least an
average Al when he passes
from as well
as be able to compete with the best of
convent
schools in that city that was the aim
and with that Target weed the school and
we did many unconventional things which
people told it's not possible but alhamd
Allah's help if we did it the timing of
a school is quite long it starts from
8:00
43 for nursery it is less we started
school from Nursery from the age of
three and the first year we had Nursery
Junior kg senior kg and first standard
only four classes only four
grades and the timing from first onwards
first upwards is from 8:00 to 4:30 and
people said the timing is too long
students won't be able to take it but
alhamdulillah we divide the day into 12
periods each of 35 minutes
on an average two periods every day are
for extracurricular activities martial
arts whether it be tando Judo swimming
whether it be computers and all the
extra activities on an average two
periods a day every child it's
compulsory should learn swimming te
Wando judo martial arts for the boys
football Etc and the balanced 10 periods
five periods are in English and five in
Arabic our school has a dual minimum
instruction English and Arabic Arabic is
the language of the
Quran it's a language in which the last
and final Revelation was revealed we
realize I realize the drawback that
because our parents did not think it
important that we should learn Arabic as
a language we know it's a drawback even
today so we want to see to it that our
children our next
Generation they should know Arabic as
the mother tongue so five periods are in
Arabic five are in
English but naturally the five periods
that are then Arabic they're Islamic
whether it be Arabic language whether it
be H whether it be taat whether it be
had whether it be Quran and all the
Islamic Studies that we have when we
give the of the Quran it's not in
English or Udu like back home in India
Pakistan we have the Islamic Studies in
Udu in the western count
we either have an Udu or we have an
English there we have an Arabic Arabic
to
Arabic so the child from the age of
three when he joins Nursery School he
starts learning Arabic when we teach him
a for Allah along with
that so from the age of three the child
is ingrained with the Arabic
language and in the Arabic period the
children can cannot speak English they
should only speak Arabic in the English
period only English know Arabic and most
of Arabic teachers they have gone to
Saudi Arabia and they've graduated from
the Islamic University of Madina so that
even the pronunciation is correct
besides the Arabic period that is there
the five periods in English one period
every day is Islamic Studies in English
that's for
dawa because a child when he does dawa
with the non-muslim it will be in
English he can't do in Arabic
there are very few Arab
non-muslims so one period is Islamic
Studies in English the balance four
perod on an average is maths English
geography History Science Etc and do the
periods if you Analyze That five per in
English is very less but we have been
able to achieve this because the ratio
of our teacher to student is very low in
Bombay on an average on average in
Bombay one school each class has 50
students some have got 60 some have got
70 some have got
80 the good schools have got 50 very few
schools have less than 50 and for every
two classes there are average three
teachers that means each teacher the
ratio of teacher and student is about 30
to 35 every 30 to 35 students have got
one teacher in Bombay and in India if
you go in the Villages it is much higher
every one teacher got 50 students on
average
and the international standard says that
it should be 1 is to 20 the good private
schools in UK USA they have every
teacher has got 10 students on
average the good private schools we in
Bombay we have every five students one
teacher each class has got 20
students on average some have got 18
some have got
19 but at times for example when there
are classes of HS so in that class of 20
students there will be five kuras coming
in Kies so each batch will have about
four students so when we have certain
classes it breaks up so that the H is
better the concentration is better so
the child can learn faster in our school
his is compulsory to standard
three till standard three the child in
nurs Jun he starts Quran he does the na
of the Quran in starts doing
in on average senior kg he memorizes
half ju first second and third every
year one and a half juw so by the time
the child complete standard
three he
memorizes at least five jws some may
memorize six some seven some may even do
four after that his is optional those
people who feel
have got a good memory we select them
maybe
25% 1/4 to 1/3 of the students and we
call them 1 hour 15 minutes earlier so
instead of coming at 8:00 in the morning
from fourth standard they come at CL to
7 now when the HS class in the morning
is conducted after third standard for
one Kar there are two students maximum
so the ratio of the kar and the students
in the higher classes is reduced one
Kari one student or one Kari two
students
maximum and only because he comes 1 hour
15 minutes early in the morning does his
for 1 hour 10 minutes in a year on an
average that child memorizes five
juw so by the time he complet the next
five years at the end of 8th standard he
memorizes the complete
Quran so so far mashallah we are in the
sixth standard in the fifth standard
according to our normal course the child
should memorize 50 18 JS but many
students mashallah at the end of fifth
standard I memorize 18 J some 19 some
even 20 so my son who's now in the sixth
he's hardly 12 years old mashallah he
knows more Quran than me he knows 20 JW
I don't know that much I'm not Quran his
Kat is better than mine he can
understand Arabic better than me he can
understand the Quran directly I can't so
we want every child in our school to be
better than what I was when I was in
school and inshallah minut minimum
minimum every child in our school
minimum is 100 times better than what I
was when I was a
child we want every child in the school
should be multiple times like me I not
the target I not the
aim I am not the sample we want them to
be multiple times better so what we
could not get in our childhood and with
Allah's
help alhamdulillah whatever we achieved
we feel that if we educate our children
in the right way right from the
childhood inshallah inshallah you will
find a change in the Next
Generation we always had a Target that
if we have to change the society we do
projects the shortterm we have
short-term dawa courses in our
foundation Islam Research Foundation
which is a crashed course for 40 days
where we train students from different
parts of the world we have international
da training program for 40 days where we
select the best people one from UK one
from USA from Singapore Malaysia Saudi
Arabia Etc and we give them a
comprehensive training course but this
scholing of 13 years is a full-fledged
dawa training program according to me
and in our school mashallah we see to it
that when they are trained not only do
they learn about Quran and Islam they
even told about Christianity about
Judaism about Hinduism about Buddhism
inshallah when a child passes school he
will be far superior than an average
Christian what he has knowledge about
Christianity what average Hindu has
knowledge about Hinduism what the
average Jew has knowledge about
[Applause]
Judaism the main aim of the school is to
make dies and see to it that they follow
the Commandments of Allah subhana wa
tala so in our school mashallah though
main two languages are English and
Arabic we also start Udu from the fourth
standard third standard is Hindi fourth
is Udu and fifth is a local language of
the state that is marati these children
mashallah they're trained in a way
that they know the values of life and we
find that many of times masallah these
children they put us to shame they put
us to
shame